so are we gonna go to nuclear war with
North Korea who knows it's on Twitter
Plus president Trump is threatening the
fake news again and Steve Bannon
completely loses his mind for the 97th
time that I'd personally know about I'm
Ben Shapiro this is the Ben Shapiro show
so many magical things happening I know
we're right back here it's a second show
of the year and already President Trump
is in top form
last night he went on Twitter and issued
some all-time great tweets and we will
go through them and they are all great
they're spectacular but first I want to
say thank you to our sponsors over at
helix leave so perhaps you lost sleep
last night not just because you were
thinking of the possibility of a nuclear
missile dropping on your home thanks to
president Trump's Twitter feed but also
because your mattress sucks well that's
why you need to go over to my friends at
helix sleep helix leap offer something
that you don't that does not exist
anywhere else a mattress that is
personalized to your unique preferences
and sleeping style that won't set you
back thousands of dollars go to helix
sleep calm / bed and you take their
simple two to three minutes sleep quiz
they ask you your body type do you like
sleeping on your back you like sleeping
on your stomach or on your side do you
like your mattress to be firm do you
like it to be soft they built a custom
mattress that will be the best thing you
have ever slept on for a couple's level
evil even personalize each side of the
mattress and then your custom mattress
arrives in the mail direct to your door
will await shipping is completely free
you open up the box you pop open the
packaging and boom it inflates right in
front of you and it is just like magic
and then you get to try for a hundred
nights if you don't like it you can
return it for free if you don't like it
they will refund you info but you will
like it and you will keep it and then
you will buy for all of your friends
because that's how good helix sleep
mattresses are goto helix sleep comm
slash pin right now and you will get 50
bucks toward your custom mattress that
is helix sleep comm slash pen for $50
off toward your Oregon that's helix
sleep comm slash Ben check it out helix
sleep comm slash Ben and I would not
leave home without it
in fact I do because I can't carry the
mattress with me but if I couldn't take
it with me then I would then I would
take the mattress with me it's that good
helix weave comm slash Ben okay so
president Trump goes off on North Korea
but I don't want to start there today I
want to save that for a few minutes from
now because it's just so glorious first
I want to discuss my old boss Steve
Bannon who apparently has lost whatever
was left of his marbles after he left
the White House Steve has been trotting
around globe-trotting
going to hot spots like Alabama said he
could talk with people about the glories
of Rome or sticking his reporters from
Breitbart news on unsuspecting alleged
victims of child molestation while his
own editor Alex Marlow was telling the
press openly that he believed the
victims but they still had
to investigate because they needed
protect Trump or something in any case
Steve Allen did an interview with an
author named Michael Wolfe I don't know
what's going through bannon's head at
this point except that he's basically
lost all connection with the White House
as far as I know he's lost all
connection with his money in the Mercer
family as far as I know and that means
that he is sort of adrift in the world
the reason that this is important is
because when the media say today that a
new controversy has arisen because of
Steve Bannon where that Steve Bannon has
the secret sauce he knows all of the
evils inside the Trump administration
when they say that he has started a new
controversy understand
Steve Bannon is desperate for relevance
Steve Bannon is not a major player on
the American political scene anymore
despite the media's wishes for him to be
so-and-so whatever he has to say about
what's going on with regard to Trump
Russia collusion you got to take it with
a grain of salt now maybe it'll turn out
that there's a smoking gun maybe it'll
turn out there was some fire there and
there was actual collusion so far I have
seen nothing of the sort so far it seems
like this is a lot of overblown rhetoric
and maybe some stupidity from people
like Carter Page and George papadopolis
but I really have seen nothing so far
that suggests in any significant way
that Trump Russia campaign collusion was
a thing well the media are jumping on
bannon's comments today because Bannon
suggests the opposite so on Wednesday
former White House chief strategist
Steve Bannon who apparently upon leaving
the White House the phone bill to the
New York Times has gone down
dramatically because Steve was good
friends some of the folks over there he
tore into his former boss President
Trump the man who made him famous as
well as Trump's son Donald Jr his
son-in-law Jared Kushner as well so
basically all of his enemies inside the
administration namely all of the Trump
kids he ripped into and then he knocked
Trump as well and then because Steve is
just an unguided missile he also back
handedly swiped his own publication
Breitbart news which was the part I
found kind of hilarious so here's what
he said he spoke with the author Michael
Wolfe from Wolf's new book that book has
now been reported by the Guardian the UK
Guardian which is a far left in
newspaper which shows you Steve has a
real tendency to talk to you the
American Prospect and the Guardian and
the New York Times you know all the fake
news media that he used to cry Bannen
told Wolff that Robert Muller's
investigation would quote crack down jr.
like an egg on national TV this is a he
only speaks in metaphors from a Martin
Scorsese film as I think it's Josh
hammer pointed
or us even though the fact is that
everything that he says is a dramatic
line from a bad film everything Bannon
says so Bannon says that they will crack
down jr. like an egg on national TV
which would be weird because that's a
crime he then stated it Donald Donald
juniors campaign meeting with lawyer
associated with the Russian government
you remember Don junior back during the
campaign had a meeting with a Russian
lawyer named vessel Nix kaya and she
came to Trump Tower and she met with
some members of the campaign the members
of the campaign basically blew her off
blew Don jr. off and despite his
willingness to hear information about
Hillary Clinton no information actually
exchanged hands as far as we know and
Trump himself was not personally
involved as far as we know in any case
here's what Bannon said he said Donald
juniors campaign meeting with that
lawyer was quote treasonous or
unpatriotic or bad bleep and added that
Trump jr. and associates should have
called the FBI immediately now this is
weird you might say to yourself wait
Steve Danon weren't you part of the
campaign if you had known about this
shouldn't you have called the FBI well
Steve banned and joined the campaign in
August this happened in July so he
wasn't there for several months I guess
or at least a couple of months before
any of this but what when any of this
was happening which means he has no
special inside information but he'd
found out about it shouldn't even call
the FBI but he didn't and then he went
on 60 minutes while he was working for
the White House you remember when we had
Trenton when we had banded on the cover
of Time magazine and he called the
Russia investigation of farce in a waste
of time remember he said this on 60
minutes and everybody said look at Steve
Bannon out there defending his boss well
now he says that his boss a traitor and
the Trump campaign was treasonous so
just as soon as Steve Bannon becomes an
irrelevant Lord of nothing just as Steve
bannon's massive power devolves into
just the bag of hot gas that he is then
all of a sudden he's back out front
saying that Trump is guilty of treason
right into the media of jump down this
is both feet off Steve Bannon must know
he was there he panthan know anything
didn't know anything the other reason
the Steve ban was on the campaign is
because the Mercer money was behind him
that's the only reason Kellyanne Conway
was on the campaign I know I was there
okay the only reason that Steven was in
the White House is because the Mercer
money who's immediately shelved in a
tiny office off the Oval Office with a
white board filled with Trump promises
that Trump had not yet fulfilled and
that Bannon would leak about to the New
York Times every so often any case it
doesn't stop there if you're
fan you should be pissed to see Bannon
today because Steve Bannon just made
trouble for Trump in the middle of Trump
actually trying to push some good policy
so Bannon went on to tell wolf that's
such a meeting should have occurred
quote in a Holiday Inn in Manchester
need to New Hampshire with your lawyers
who meet with these people and
information should then have been dumped
down to Breitbart or something like that
or maybe some other more legitimate
publication so a few things about this
are hilarious
number one if you just said that it was
a treasonous meeting how does it make it
not treasonous if your lawyers are in
New Hampshire with them and it's still
treason so I'm confused about that but
my favorite thing by far in this
interview his war ban and says that the
information from the Russians should
have been dumped down to Breitbart right
first of all implying the Breitbart was
basically a vehicle for the Trump
administration and the Trump campaign
which it was and that they should have
acted illegally or at least colluded
with the Russians that Trump should have
used Breitbart as basically a go-between
with the Russian government which is
incredible admission and then finally
the admission that maybe they should
have dumped that information to some
other more legitimate publications this
ban and who is the chairman of Breitbart
news calling his own publication
illegitimate so well done Steve just
remember this guy's Darth Vader remember
he's the great genius he's the great the
great unbreakable brilliant honey badger
who was behind the Trump campaign uh-huh
or is it possible he's just a doof is it
just possible he's a loudmouth doof and
the media treat him as something special
because they hate Trump and so they want
to make it seem like bandhans the real
power behind the throne he didn't stop
there he says about Jared Kushner quote
you realize where this is going this is
all about money laundering okay well
first of all we knew that already
because Kushner was interviewed and they
requested bank records so thanks for the
revelation Steve he says Muller chose
Andrew Weissman a prosecutor first and
he has a money laundering guide their
path to effing Trump goes right through
Paul Manafort town jr. and Jared Kushner
it's as plain as a hair on your face
it goes through Deutsche Bank and all
the cushion of bleep the commissioner
bleep is greasy they're gonna go right
through that they're gonna roll up those
two guys and say play me or trade me
they're sitting on a beach trying to
stop a category five again everything he
says is from a bad movie trailer every
single thing Steve Benton has ever said
is from a bad movie trailer it's just
spectacular and what's so great about
this is that Bannon just blew himself up
with the people who made him famous
now I understand the Bandon thinks he's
gonna go with Jovanka right with Jordan
Ivanka that's his thing he's gonna go to
war with Jordan Ivanka
right but no one cares about that no one
cares about Steve bannon's little petty
internation fights the only thing people
care about at least where I come from in
the conservative movement is whether
Trump gets things done or not whether
Trump is winning or not for the policies
that we like I don't care whether Trump
even personally wins I care whether he
does policy that I like yeah but see
Bannon is out there making trouble for
Trump and now the media are going to
jump all over him of course and they're
gonna try to turn this into a big story
because they've been building up Bannen
as something he is not for a long time I
have been saying consistently for well
over a year now
Steve Bannon is not a powerful figure
Steve Bannon doesn't know anything Steve
Bannon is a leech on the ass of power
who rode Michele Bachmann's name to
Sarah Palin to Andrew Breitbart who died
to Donald Trump to the Mercer family
okay that's all that happened here
that's all that happened here but the
media will jump on this so ignore all
the media bloviating about how Trump has
abandoned he has the inside scoop
he just doesn't okay moving on now we
can finally talk about president Trump's
magnificent set of tweets last night
magnificent okay so I don't know whether
Trump just has you know John Adams once
said about Alexander Hamilton that
Alexander Hamilton had a had in a what
was it a plethora of secretions there
were not enough Horrors in the world to
suck off okay I am not joking that's
something that John Adams actually said
about Alexander Hamilton I don't know
whether Trump just builds up Twitter
secretions and then he has to let them
off on Twitter I don't know they just he
builds up steam and then he has to let
it all off on Twitter I'm not sure what
the story is there but whatever the
story is it's spectacular
okay whatever the story is it is it is
magical so last night Donald Trump takes
to Twitter and nothing prompts this like
it wasn't like Kim jong-un did anything
or like he tweeted at him or any of that
sort of thing instead Donald Trump
tweeted this thing and I will read it to
you in just a second but first I want to
say thank you to our sponsors over at
Skillshare so you're getting your resume
ready for this year you don't want to be
at that job I know you don't you know
you don't write this way you're
listening my show at your workplace
right now okay the reality is you want a
better job with more money well the way
to make that happen
the best way to make that happen is to
make your skills better right to make
your resume deeper and that is what
Skillshare does it's an online learning
program with over
18,000 classes and design business
technology and more whether you're
trying to deepen your professional skill
set or start a site of hustle or just
explore something new that's what
Skillshare is for so I've taken some of
their social media marketing classes I
took one on watercolours as I say one
day my watercolors will be sold in a
museum alongside Churchill's or
alternatively they will go directly in
the trash bin but one of those two
things will happen thanks to skill sure
skill share is offering then Shapiro
show listeners a limited time offer of
three months of skill share for just 99
cents which is pretty awesome deal sign
up go to skills share comm slash Shapiro
99 that skill shared comm slash Shapiro
99 don't forget the 99 skills shared
comm slash appear nines now you get
three months of skill share for just 99
cents right act now for the special New
Year's offer start learning today you
have all these resolutions how you're
gonna make your life better how you
gonna make your career better skills
share can help you do that get off your
butt sign up for skill share right now
or alternatively sit on your butt and
sign up for skill share right now and
then take the classes while sitting on
your butt because the classes I brought
directly to you through your computer
skill share comm slash Shapiro 99 that's
Shapiro 99 and that lets them know that
we sent you okay so here is this this is
just spectacular it's a Trump tweets
this out North Korea North Korean leader
Kim Jung hoon just stated that the
nuclear button is on his desk at all
times with someone from his depleted and
food stabbed regime please inform him
that I to have a nuclear button but it
is a much bigger and more powerful one
than his and my button works amazeballs
okay just amazing Donald Trump likes big
buttons and he cannot lie that is just
that is glorious there is is is it what
can you say except we're all going to
die
so are we actually all going tonight so
the media treated it as though we are
all going tonight media treated this as
though it is the end of the world as we
know it and they don't feel fine the
media a lot of pop culture references
today the media has basically went crazy
over this so an MSNBC analyst because
this this actually it poses for analysis
on MSNBC his name is Anand you read
Herodotus
she's a name for you and he says that
Trump's sexual insecurities are
threatening to destroy the planet so
Donald Trump is very obsessed with his
genital size and therefore
he's tweeting this out and then we're
all going to die so he's in all in with
Chris Hayes talking about again the show
is called
all in with Chris Hayes and he's talking
about sexual insecurity on national TV
anyway here is the MSNBC analyst the
famed MSNBC analyst anon garage Harada
Brad abyss perhaps never have we seen a
man whose profound sexual and masculine
insecurities are literally threatening
to annihilate the planet I mean the way
he's literally capitalizing and that
tweet is nuclear button I mean any
psychiatrist or psychologists would have
a field day with that but we all live in
a world that could literally be ended in
terms of a habitable planet no no it
won't no no come on really okay the
truth is no one takes from seriously
about this stuff no one cares
Trump says a lot of crap no one is like
really is anybody at this point going
yes we're really all going to die
and Ross dude had I thought had a great
point on Twitter last night if people
actually thought that everyone's gonna
die don't you think there'll be millions
of people in the streets protesting from
sweater feed but don't you think that
there would be like some people going
guys this be crazy right wouldn't there
be anybody who's like oh my god bilder
what wouldn't wouldn't all of my
sponsors who sell survival gear be just
doing unbelievably well because of these
tweets they're doing unbelievably well
because they sponsored with me but
wouldn't they be doing unbelievably well
because of the survival because of the
tweets wouldn't that be what's going on
no none of that's happening because no
one takes this seriously okay the
reality is then if Trump's tweets are
gonna have any impact on foreign policy
it's not gonna be because of stuff like
this okay Jimmy Kimmel though he also
goes crazy over this so Pope Jimmy is
Mary Katharine ham has termed him he
comes out he did not have his son on his
hip for this one but he did say that
there are two this is this is just
insane two maniacs arguing over who has
the bigger button he took some time off
he almost seems like a new man he's very
positive tonight just minutes ago he
tweeted North Korean leader Kim Jong
hoon just stated that the nuclear button
is on his desk at all times well someone
from his depleted and food starved
regime please inform him that I too have
a nuclear button but it is a much bigger
and more power
one than his my button works that's
right Happy New Year everybody
we have two maniacs with nuclear
warheads bragging about who has the
bigger button okay so I love this first
of all I wish that I had pulled the clip
of Willy Wonka saying button button
who's got the button because it would be
so perfect here but in any case Jimmy
Kimmel saying oh it's too many yet but
everyone's laughing right that's the
point people immediately start laughing
when they hear that tweet they don't go
oh my god we're all gonna die they go
that's kind of funny
cuz you know what it's kind of funny it
is okay like Trump saying I have a
bigger first of all that button on his
desk it just brings some Diet Coke guys
okay that button is not for the nukes
right the phone is for the nukes the
button is just for the Diet Coke so we
can hope that he doesn't switch the
phone in the button right we hope that
he doesn't pick up the phone and order
himself two diet cokes and people take
that as a code right but at the same
time come on like this idea that we're
all going to die now is it stable
behavior is it the kind of behavior that
we would wish to see from the president
would you expect this from Abraham
Lincoln Abraham Lincoln just would would
tweet out silly Jefferson Davis I have
an enormous army on your doorstep it's
long beautiful and hard is that really
what you would expect from Abraham
Lincoln probably not probably not from
Honest Abe it's not what we're used to
in the Oval Office
Jake Tapper goes after Trump over this
yesterday this is the President of the
United States issuing a threat to use
nuclear weapons and then turning around
and glibly chastising the media these
tweets coming on the same day the
president Trump also suggested that a
former Hillary Clinton aide who has been
charged with no crime should be jailed
and said the former FBI director who was
in a witness who is a witness in the
investigation into the Trump campaign
should be investigated himself and also
said that his own Justice Department is
part of a conspiracy known as the quote
deep State none of this normal none of
this acceptable none of this frankly
stable behavior okay so this is just
like there is that true yeah it's kind
of true I mean like is this something
you would expect from the president but
but this idea that we're all going to
die because of it is just not true okay
the reality is that if you were going to
actually have a situation in which the
President of the United States is a
threat on foreign policy it would not be
because of this right Ronald Reagan back
in 1984 I believe during his re-election
campaign he was caught on a live mic
saying the bombing of the Soviet
begins in five minutes right and it's in
everybody laughed actually the Soviets
took it seriously enough they have to
put their bombers on alert because
people took Reagan seriously did North
Korea put its bombers on alert no North
Korea did nothing because no one's
taking from seriously on this if there
were to be any danger from Trump's
Twitter feed its if Trump would start
signaling friendliness or apathy toward
a regime you should not so for example
let's say that Vladimir Putin were to
mass a bunch of troops on the border of
Estonia or Latvia and Trump were to say
well I didn't care about those places I
don't even know how to spell them right
then you would say okay well now we're
on the brink of war right cuz Putin's
just gonna walk right across that border
knowing Trump's not gonna do anything
because even when from Bluffs with fours
there's a good shot that the force is
never gonna come so if he actually says
he doesn't care about something he
probably really doesn't care about
something but as far as him making
militaristic threats like that's what
why do you think Trump wanted the job
it's just so he could say this kind of
stuff it's just so he like Trump does
have some deep insecurity right there's
no question he he has some some deep
insecurity but no one's taking this
seriously anymore which is why I tweeted
out last night that I think the
President Trump should simultaneously
launch nuclear weapons at North Korea
during the State of the Union address in
which is railing about fake news and
fire Robert Mueller at the same time
then the next day he should start
tweeting about why no one is talking
about the stock market gains like that
seems like that seems like I think the
best move for president Trump at this
point okay so I'm moving on I want to
talk a little bit more about another
tweet that President Trump sent out and
it is real and it is spectacular it is
it is quite grand but first I want to
say thank you to our sponsors over at
stamps.com so stamps.com is the place to
go if you need you might have guessed it
stamps right if you need postage then
stamps calm is the place to go they
bring all the amazing services of the US
Postal Service directly to your computer
it is the better way to get postage
simply use your computer to print
official US postage for any letter or
package any class of mail and let the
mailman pick it up no leaving the office
no more lugging mail to the post office
no more hassle they save you time they
save you money you don't have to wait in
line at the post Docs you may enjoy the
post office but still you want to save
time stay at home print out all of your
postage you can print it directly onto
the envelope you can print it onto a
sticker you can print it onto a piece of
paper and tape it to the envelope right
now you can enjoy stamps comm service
with a special offer that includes a
four week trial plus postage and the
digital scale okay that's four week try
plus postage in digital scale if you're
ready for a better New Year go to stamps
comm click on the microphone at the top
of the homepage type in Shapiro you get
that special deal remember stamps comm
there's a little microphone click on it
hit Shapiro and that stamps comm enter
promo code Shapiro to get that four-week
trial plus postage n the digital scale
pretty solid deal just for using that
promo code Shapiro okay so that wasn't
the only great Trump tweet that was sent
out yesterday here is another fantastic
Trump tweet that was sent out yesterday
so Trump tweets out quote I would be
announcing all capitals the most
dishonest and corrupt media awards of
the year on Monday at 5 o'clock
subjects will cover dishonesty and bad
reporting in various categories from the
fake news media stay tuned okay so first
of all I continue to enjoy his
capitalization habits they are just I
don't know it say about them like
normally you know you're reading I've
been reading a lot of philosophy lately
and very often you'll see philosophers
use terms that they've coined right
you'll you'll see the new manal and the
phenomenal and in conte and sometimes in
certain editions they will actually
capitalize those terms because there are
new terms that are being introduced in
contracts we do the same thing in
contract law whenever we introduce a new
term in parentheses we put all caps what
the term means right we capitalized it
but apparently Trump things he coined
the terms dishonesty and bad reporting
and from the fake news media and I what
I'm hoping is that President Trump
actually says that he wants to deliver a
nationally televised address and deliver
his diatribe against the fake news media
on all three networks that would be
pretty spectacular and I'll admit I'm
gonna tune in on Monday at five o'clock
like is he gonna do it on Twitter is it
gonna be an actual reality show are they
gonna be a Wars presenters is it gonna
be like Kim Kardashian walks out who's
gonna actually be the emcee is he gonna
emcee it himself or is he gonna be the
guy who just comes out and it opens up
the envelopes I am very curious as to
how this is going to go is gonna be Ted
Nugent and Sarah Palin in the Oval
Office actually making this happen
or won't be the mooch I root for the
mooch on behalf of Marshall one of the
producers here I root for the mooch and
I would try to get Marshall front-row
seats for the mooch but in any case
President Trump going after the fake
news media as well again I don't know
what's driving these tweets but I can
safely say that it's nothing supremely
rational he also tweeted about his
accomplishments last night and this one
was pretty good he he really
one on Twitter last night and I like
that the president has fun with things
he tweeted out president Trump has
something now he didn't have a year ago
that is a set of accomplishments that
nobody can deny the accomplishments are
there look at his record he has had a
very significant first year and then he
quotes it from the Lou Dobbs show David
Asman and Ed Rollins so I do love that
he is now giving citations so that's
exciting um also a few days ago the
President of the United States suggested
that he did not in fact watch a lot of
TV that's not true he watches a lot of
TV so here is Trump on Daniel Dale who
is a reporter I believe was he for ABC
or Axios in any case he he tweets out
they he tweeted out Trump's schedule
yesterday
11:03 p.m. live tweets fox business 8:16
p.m. urges people to watch fox show 7:49
a I assume these are all I am or I guess
the I guess is this the last 24 hours
okay 749 p.m. mocks Kim jong-un after
Fox segment 959 13 a.m. takes credit for
aviation safety after Fox segment 9:08
a.m. talks North Korea after fox segment
849 am tweets about taxes after fox
segment 844 am tweets to fox 748 am
attacks Justice Department Abaddon after
fox segment that also actually I think I
missed a couple I think the traumatic a
couple of five segments as well I mean
at least Fox knows who they're who
they're P ones are right in radio you
call them the P ones the people who
listen to your entire show at least I
mean they they know who they're who they
are programming to so you know the
President of the United States I can't
say he's a deeply busy man now look at
the good news about this I guess if
you're on the left is that he's not busy
doing other things like he could be busy
paring back regulations and if you're on
the right he could be busy doing other
things like I guess mouthing off but he
is mouthing off so I guess is that all
great here is the problem that I'm
having a more broad problem I've been
talking about this a lot because let's
face it it's freaking hilarious I mean
it's just funny it's just funny okay if
you can't enjoy this then take a chill
pill because it is it is it is one of
the more enjoyable things in life is
watching the President of the United
States who seems as though the the music
from Benny Hill should be running under
the administration
continuously here is the problem the
actual problem the actual problem is I
am now invested in
president Trump's policies I like his
policies over the last six weeks I've
gotten a lot of good policy in the
middle of these sweet storms that I've
been talking about he tweeted that
perhaps he should cut aid to the
Palestinian Authority which he should
it's a terrorist entity right in the
middle of all of this he was saying
things that are true about the Middle
East and Iran he was tweeting out that
the United States was going to support
the protesters in Iran all of this is
true and good and important now if the
President of the United States had but
let's say the President of the United
States had had been pushing nationalist
populist Bandhan ISM an agenda that I
didn't like let's say I was pushing a
bunch of policy that I thought was bad
and then he was doing all of this stuff
that was stupid I would say well it's
not great the president the United
States is doing all that stuff but what
he's really doing is he's maligning an
agenda that is not my own he's hitting a
magenta an agenda and I am not
particularly fond of so the impact on
that agenda it makes less of a
difference to me right if he if he has
if he sinks his own infrastructure bill
I'm not gonna shed any tears over that
but if the President of the United
States is pushing policies that I like a
lot right as he's been doing for the
last six weeks
now there's the significant possibility
that in 2018 if he loses the house or if
he loses the Senate or if things really
go to hell in a handbasket he loses in
2020 that it's not just going to be seen
as a repudiation of him personally and
his Twitter habits it's not just gonna
be seen as a repudiation of the of the
President of the United States as a
human being it will instead be a seen as
a repudiation of his policies and my
business partner Jeremy boring God king
of daily wire Jeremy has been saying
this for years about Herbert Hoover what
he said about Herbert Hoover is that if
you actually look back at Herbert
Hoover's record right the president who
preceded FDR his record was very much
along the lines of FDR's record and he
increased government spending
he pushed tariffs he increased
regulations
he was very interventionist in the
economy in fact members of the FDR
administration said openly that Herbert
Hoover's policies were basically the
groundwork for their own but then in
1932 and he ran for re-election and
afterward he posed himself as a as a
real conservative is a guy who wanted
small government less government
intervention ISM and so Hoover ism
became synonymous with conservatism and
it's smeared conservatism for a
generation a full generation didn't
matter that Herbert Hoover wasn't
actually conservative his toxicity
smeared conservatism even though his own
policies
not been conservative this is what I
fear from Trump and in some ways worse
because he's actually implementing
policies that I like as I don't have to
go through the litany again but in the
last month in the last six weeks he has
announced the move of the capital of the
embassy to Jerusalem in Israel he has
gotten his major tax cut which will not
be reversed
he's nominate a bunch more appellate
court judge the judges yesterday at Don
Willett and joined the 5th Circuit Court
of Appeals which is a fantastic pick ton
well it is terrific he has cut
regulations at record rates he is he has
prevented the establishment of new
national monuments and is paring back on
some of the old ones because there's too
much federal land in the West presidents
of the United States has supported the
protesters and run all this is good
stuff
but if the president makes himself toxic
and therefore makes his agenda toxic
then you do have a much more serious
problem on your hands and that is not
good okay that's not it's not a good
thing that's something that has to stop
and so I encouraged the president to go
on break and just enjoy himself instead
he went around to to Twitter and said
things and that's not good again I just
want I want the president to be
successful for the country and I don't
think that these tweets are particularly
helpful in that now with that said the
President of the United States did tweet
something about the deep state yesterday
that is not completely inaccurate so
here's what he tweeted yesterday tweeted
quote crooked Hillary Hillary Clinton's
top aide Huma Abedin has been accused of
disregarding basic security protocols
she put classified passwords into the
hands of foreign agents remember sailors
pictures on summer in jail deep State
Justice Department must finally act also
on Comey and others so what he's
suggesting here is that Hillary
Clinton's top aide who may Abbadon
should go to jail because she actually
put a bunch of passwords like government
passwords on her yahoo email and that
yahoo was then hacked and what trump
says that he's comparing this to another
case are they of a woman who was jailed
she was in the US Navy and she was
jailed for taking pictures on submarines
and then putting them on social media
and this was considered a security
breach and she did time in jail and he
again is suggesting that the Justice
Department is the deep state well the
President of the United States the head
of the Justice Department he can
instruct them to investigate Hillary
Clinton in Huma Abedin any time he wants
he has not done that instead he prefers
to mouth off about it but is it true
that the Justice
has acted in heretofore bizarre ways and
did so while it was under the auspices
of the Obama administration has
continued to act in I would say slightly
less weird ways which have sessions but
the Comey investigation Robert Mueller's
investigation has acted in strange ways
I think that that's unquestionable and
in just a second I want to tell you
about the situation with Trump Russia
and Hillary because there's an op-ed in
The New York Times that is quite telling
but first Jeffrey Toobin on CNN went off
over the deep state here's what he had
to say about Trump ripping the so-called
deep state again well I think it's
pretty reprehensible to use that that
phraseology in any event I guess who
that refers to or long-serving civil
servants career civil servants who are
patriots and dedicated to the to the
country I'd point out that when you take
the oath of office as a civil servant
you swear to uphold the Constitution it
doesn't say anything about pledging
loyalty to this president or any other
and if not doing so is what constitutes
being part of the South deep State I
think that's that's actually James
clapper but James clapper you know
talking about the deep state this is the
problem right when James clapper says
that Trump is wrong about the deep state
who's gonna trust James clapper about
that because James clapper was a
motivated part of the so-called deep
State when people say deep state I think
they're think of something more
conspiratorial than is it's just Obama
holdovers who have a political agenda
and there's no question that there are
people in positions of power who do have
that agenda again it was the Daily
Caller that reported that Abaddon forded
her State Department passwords to Yahoo
before was hacked by Florida agents
Luke Rossi who does some really good
investigative reporting over there he's
the one who reported on this yesterday
he said that you know who by Abaddon
regularly forded work email store
personal account and then she'd used
these accounts if her State account was
was down or she need to print an email
or document abdun further explained that
it was difficult to print from the
Department of State system so she
routinely forwarded emails to earn on
gos system which of course defeats the
entire purpose Trump's not wrong to ask
questions about the behavior of the
Obama administration and the so called
deep state during this time I just think
that it's not smart of him to tweet it
out there plenty of people who can ask
those questions for him well in just a
second I want to discuss in
edie from fusion GPS that a lot of
people are apparently suggesting puts an
end to all of the blowback on the
Mueller team for corruption but it
doesn't I'll explain why in just a
second first I want to say thank you to
our new sponsor is over at wondering
there's a new podcast that you just have
to listen to it's called American
history tellers I've listened to their
trailer and part of their first podcast
and it really is terrific so here is the
question how well do you know your
history and talking about the stories
that make up America and American
history American history tellers puts
you inside the shoes of everyday people
in time a place or event that made
history right now they are doing the
Cold War the first six episodes they
dropped today January 3rd and the new
series covers the Cold War you can start
listening to the first episode right now
you don't have to be a huge history buff
who's into all of the minutia and dates
that's not what American history tellers
is it's hosted by Lindsey Graham not
that Lindsey Graham and he is a history
buff and he teams up with PhD historians
to bring you a new take on history
telling they use a first-person
perspective but sound design to really
get history stuck in your mind it's
terrific I've listened to it it's
entertaining it's interesting and it is
memorable because your mind tends to
remember narrative and this is a
narrative history series check out
American history tellers on Apple
podcasts or wherever you listen to
podcasts make sure you subscribe as well
American history tellers check it out
subscribe today again it's called
American history tellers well worth the
listen really interesting stuff okay so
there's an op-ed in The New York Times
that the left is trotting out as
evidence that the right is
conspiratorial in its views of the
Mueller investigation so to recap as I
said yesterday the right has suggested
that there's a serious problem with the
FBI investigation into Trump Russia
collusion the serious problem is that
the fusion GPS dossier that was
allegedly used as the basis for FBI
attempting to get FISA warrants on Trump
administration officials was
commissioned by Democrats and was full
of crap basically there were Democrats
inside the DOJ and the FBI they were
politically motivated they got a hold of
this dossier from fusion GPS which was a
democratic funded Apple Research Group
basically and then they used that as an
excuse to go after Trump that's the
allegation from Republicans well today
the the the cofounders of fusion GPS
Glenn Simpson and Peter fresh one of
whom pled the fifth in front of Congress
right they have an op-ed today talking
about how fusion GPS has
thing to do it that we did nothing wrong
and the FBI investigation has nothing to
do with fusion GPS etcetera so here's
what they write they say a generation
ago Republicans sought to protect
President Richard Nixon by urging the
Senate Watergate committee to look at
supposed wrongdoing by Democrats in
previous elections the committee
chairman Sam Ervin and Democrat said
that would be quote as foolish as the
man who went bear hunting and stopped to
chase rabbits today I'm in a growing and
criminal inquiry into Russian meddling
in the 2016 election congressional
Republicans are again chasing rabbits we
know because we are their favorite
quarry in the air since the publication
of the so-called steel dossier the
collection of intelligence reports we
commissioned about Donald Trump's ties
to Russia the president has repeatedly
attacked us on Twitter his allies in
Congress have dug through our bank
records and sought to tarnish our firm
to punish us for highlighting his links
to Russia conservative news outlets and
even our former employer The Wall Street
Journal has spun a succession of
mendacious conspiracy theories about our
motives and backwards
we are happy to correct the record in
fact we already have three congressional
committees have heard over 21 hours of
testimony from our firm fusions ups
again they're neglecting to mention
several members of fusions UPS pled the
fifth they say we walked investigators
through a year-long effort to decipher
mr. Trump's complex business past of
which the steel dossier is but one
chapter and we handed over our relevant
bank records while drawing the line at a
fishing expedition for the records of
companies we work for that have nothing
to do with the Trump case well they drew
they don't really get to decide where
they draw the line in a subpoena
situation you know one of the questions
is who funds you right who bankrolls you
the Republicans have refused to release
full transcripts of our firms testimony
even as they selectively leaked details
to media outlets on the far right well
I'd like to see them released full
transcripts because I'd like to see what
was said I would also like to find out
who pled the fifth and why they say we
don't believe the steel dossier was the
trigger for the FBI's investigation into
Russian meddling as we told the Senate
Judiciary Committee in August our
sources said the dossier was taken so
seriously because it corroborated
reports the bureau had received from
other sources including one inside at
the Trump camp there are some problems
with this particular claim the dossier
corroborated reports from other sources
they only started monitoring George
papadopolis apparently after the Stasi a
came out is my understanding of a
timeline so I'm not understanding how
they could corroborate reports that had
already been issued unless those were
basically just reportedly Zoar rumors
and the intelligence committees have
known for months the credible
allegations of Clue
between the Trump camp and Russia were
pouring in from independent sources
during the campaign lawmakers in thrall
of the president continue to wage a
cynical campaign to portray as the
unwitting victims of kremlin
disinformation and then they say that
they'd suggested investigators look into
bank records of Deutsche Bank and others
funding Trump's business Congress
appeared an uninterested in our tip we
told Congress that we found widespread
evidence that mr. Trump in his
organization had worked with a wide
array of dubious Russians okay all of
that is being investigated by Mueller
but I'm just confused in general by this
claim that the dossier had nothing to do
with the original launch of the of the
wiretap on Carter page because there is
nothing about George papadopolis that
suggests that you actually have to
launch a wiretap against Carter page and
that's what the FISA warrant was for
Carter page was apparently only
mentioned in the fusion GPS dossier so
again there there's something fishy here
I'm not sure that all of this washes for
me well meanwhile congressional
investigators are saying they found
written evidence of criminality in the
Clinton probe so according to the hill
Republicans on congressional committees
conducting their own investigations have
obtained highly redacted documents from
the FBI that showed the agency did
suspect that laws were broken
lawmakers say in numerous passages the
FBI stated the sheer volume of
classified information that flowed to
and from the former Secretary of State's
unsecured private server was proof of
criminality there was also an admission
of false statements by a key witness the
name of the witness was redacted
congressional investigators say it was
an employee from the computer firm that
maintained Clinton's server after she
left the State Department in 2013 so in
other words the FBI shut down a fully
plausible investigation into Hillary
Clinton but launched a really sketchy
investigation into Trump Russia again
the only indictments that have come down
right now are from Mike Flynn on
obstructing justice by lying to the FBI
and during the transition and George
papadopolis who apparently lied to the
FBI about reach outs from in London
contacts who apparently had contacts
with the Russian government right that's
that's about all that we have so far
from the Mueller investigation well
meanwhile the president continues to try
to push forward an agenda the Trump is
trying to push forward his agenda and
that agenda has been slightly hampered
by the news that Orrin Hatch is out the
senator from Utah who was widely seen as
the only barrier between Mitt
and the Senate seat in Utah he has
decided that he is going to step out of
the Senate he's 1,000 years old I
believe he may be 1,001 he's he's
actually 83 and Orrin Hatch has been in
the Senate for 41 years so significantly
longer than I have been alive he has
actually been in the Senate and hatch is
leaving and he also has said that he is
fine with Mitt Romney taking over for
him
Romney who is 70 changed his changed his
Twitter profile to highlight the fact
that he is located in Holladay Utah so
it looks like Romney is likely to run a
lot of people in the Trump camp are not
happy about this they think that Romney
will be a thorn in Trump's side in the
same way that Jeff Flake was sort of a
thorn in Trump's side again I think that
Romney will likely vote a lot of the
right way on all of this but I'm
confused as to you know I don't know why
Romney is necessarily the logical pick I
think he'll make a fine senator from
Utah I don't see any serious problems
there although you know we'll have to go
back and rehash his record the guy did
invent Obamacare so making him into the
greatest Obamacare opponent there's
always this revisionist history that
goes on after campaigns in 2012 I did
not vote for Mitt Romney in the
primaries in northern and I endorsed him
in the primary specifically because I
didn't think he was quite as
conservative as he was pledging to be
right so I was pretty clear about my
doubts about Romney then I think a lot
of the passion about Romney now is
driven by the fact that he is seen as a
counterweight to Trump in reality will
he be that he'll say some stuff but will
he actually be that not in any way
different than Jeff Flake has been which
is to say not much what else on the
Republican agenda for 2018 well now
they're talking about welfare reform so
I think Trump is on a different page
than some of the members of Congress
Trump is talking about immigration per
se Steve Scalise who is the House
Majority Whip he is saying we're gonna
tackle welfare reform next again this
would be a greatly necessary change this
would be useful well there's a lot that
we're going to be doing in 2018 and it
starts where we left off tax reform is
working incredibly well we're seeing our
economy take off the next big thing
you're going to see is a need for
workers and I think the best thing we
can do is to go and reform those welfare
programs that are trapping people in a
failed welfare state let's actually put
some work requirements in place so that
we can get people back to work rebuild
the middle class
okay so this is a useful piece of
information Trump is also pushing along
an agenda with regard to daca so
yesterday I mentioned that Trump didn't
seem to have any clear strategy on the
deferred action for childhood arrivals
program and that's a problem right it
seems like he's saying that he's gonna
reinstate daca if Democrats don't reach
a deal with him which would not be a
loss for Democrats it would look like
Trump back down it looked like he backed
down his base would be angry at him so
I'm not sure how that's even close to a
negotiation strategy but there are
members of Trump administration now who
are saying the Trump is not going to
sign into law any deal for the dreamers
almost it also includes an end to chain
migration and what's fascinating is
they're sort of a rip that's broken out
among Republicans about whether Trump
should go for a border funding for the
wall or whether he should go for an end
to chain migration if you have to pick
one you have to go with chair migration
mai-chan migration is significantly more
of a problem in terms of immigration and
illegal immigration then is the border
wall itself right we can always staff up
ice there is border wall in some places
already I I'm in favor of border wall
I've always been in favor of a border
barrier no question but if you have to
choose chain migration is a much greater
threat to America's immigration system
than is the border wall because that's
basically a legal policy that says that
if you come in and you get in you now
get to bring all of your extended family
it turns into fit week the big hearted
moves from dr. Seuss I used to bring in
everybody on your horns and that that's
a huge mistake right the the latest
terror attack that we saw in the United
States was perpetrated by somebody who
got in basically through a chain
migration so that that's not a if
they're gonna go for something let them
go for chain migration I think that's
the right move again the American
immigration system changed radically in
1965 and it was designed instead of for
making America stronger through
immigration it was designed instead to
be based on empathy for people from
various parts of the globe
that might be more downtrodden coming
from places that were less European in
origin places that had typically less of
a history of Western civilization and
that changed how immigration was done
the chain migration system combined with
that shift in the place where people
come from means that a higher percentage
of people are coming from countries that
are not used to all of the all of the
things that make Western civilization
Western civilization so I hope that
trump can push that it's one of the
reasons why please mr. president stop
with the Twitter distractions stop it's
just not useful in any real way okay so
in just a second I'm gonna do some
things I like and some things that I
hate but first we're gonna have to say
goodbye to you over on Facebook and
YouTube so I have Facebook and YouTube
if you want to subscribe and watch the
rest of the show live all you have to do
is go over to daily wire comm for $9.99
a month you too can have a subscription
to daily wire comm and with that
subscription comes the rest of our show
on video live with that comes your
capacity to participate in the mailbag
on Fridays which is just it'll make your
life that much better you can watch the
rest of mandrel clave in the show live
you can watch the rest of Michael Moses
show live be part of the inner mailbags
as well when we have the conversation
which is a big wait which is our big Q&A
that we do on a not infrequent basis you
get to ask your questions so you get to
have all these things plus the Shapiro's
story is coming in if you get the annual
subscription you still get this be very
greatest in all tumblers for 2018 if you
are if you have a surplus of leftists
ears that are just wetting the floor in
your home you cannot do better than get
this leftist cheers hot or cold tumbler
often imitated never duplicated
significantly better than any other
competitor on the market no matter what
they will tell you about asbestos
there is no asbestos in this tumbler
it's fantastic so check that out with
the annual subscription or go over to
iTunes SoundCloud Google Play stitcher
any of those places you can listen to
our show or go over to youtube please
hit subscribe over at YouTube we always
have great videos coming out including
some excerpts from my debate with Sam
Harris that I think we've put up on our
YouTube channel so you can check that
out as well so lots of fun over there we
are the largest fastest-growing
conservative podcast in the nation
okay time for some things I like him
then some things I hate so things I like
I'm the President of the United States
um I mentioned this amid his tweets
yesterday I made the crazy tweets there
was a very good tweet okay and the tweet
that he put out was with regard to
Pakistan and then with regard to the
Palestinians here it was - tweet he
tweeted quote it's not only Pakistan we
paid billions of dollars - for nothing
right he cut off military aid to
Pakistan which is a good move but also
many other countries as well as an
example we pay the Palestinians hundreds
of millions of dollars a year and get no
appreciation or respect they don't even
want to negotiate a long overdue peace
treaty with Israel we've taken Jerusalem
toughest part of the negotiation off the
table but Israel for that would have had
to pay more than what the Palestinians
no longer willing to talk peace why
should we make any of these massive
future payments to them this is a good
question we never should have been
making these massive future payments to
them at all because they are a terrorist
group the Palestinian Authority is a
terrorist group in a terrorist coalition
with Islamic Jihad in the terrorists
coalition with the with Hamas the idea
that we pay the money taxpayer money my
money is totally insane by the way he
did not take Jerusalem off the table for
for Israel right he just said we're not
gonna pressure Israel on Jerusalem which
is not quite the same thing
the US has budgeted 251 million dollars
in aid for the West Bank the Judea and
Samaria and the Gaza Strip in 2018 that
means money for Hamas we should cut off
that aid immediately now we should have
done it years ago and good for Trump for
doing it hopefully he will actually
follow up on that
okay other things that I like so there's
a book that I read over the weekend and
it's it's kind of interesting it's it's
a book by a guy named Albert J nock this
was written and I think 1934 the book is
called our enemy the state now there are
a lot of people who are sort of
anarcho-capitalists or big fans of this
book because the basic premise of the
book is that there's a difference
between government and the state the
state is this this instrument of power
that is used in order to harness wealth
for a particular few I obviously agree
with that general premise where I think
he goes off the rails he's a very
Charles beardian analysis of the
American Founding he basically suggests
that the American founders were seeking
to enrich themselves and that's why they
founded the country in the way that they
did as a republic he prefers the
Articles of Confederation system because
he thinks that a non centralized
American government was a better
solution
I disagree with him on some of this
analysis but I think that he makes a
good case for the idea that the sort of
German progressive style state has taken
over America's perception Americans
perception of what the state should do
and we need to rethink that the
government should basically be returned
to as far of a local system as possible
it's really interesting when I was
growing up I was a big fan of John Adams
I still am a fan of John Adams as I get
older I tend to be more friendly to
Jeffersonian philosophy with regard to
devolution of authority to local
government John Adams obviously was in
favor of more centralization of function
in the federal government John Jefferson
was precisely the reverse but Jefferson
also was happy to use the federal
government to do the Louisiana Purchase
an unconstitutional move that he felt
would enrich the country so knock is not
completely incorrect when he says that
it's pretty easy for people who view
themselves as small government advocates
to becoming advocates a big government
when it's useful for them become part of
the state apparatus now the book is
called our enemy of the state and it is
worth a read again it's more of an
anarchist book than than it is an
anarchist book than it is a conservative
book per se but it was apparently
informative and for from William F
Buckley among others okay time for a
couple of things that I hate okay so
we'll do one quick thing that I hate it
was a couple of quick things that I hit
I suppose so okay so there's a New York
Times op-ed today from a woman named
Kishan Akali all about how Erica garner
her death on Saturday is the fault of
the American system or somesuch so Erika
Garner you'll recall is the daughter of
Eric garner Eric garner is the guy who
died after he was put in a in a
suppression hold by the New York City
Police Department for selling loosies
which were cigarettes that were not
licensed because the cigarette taxes are
so high there are people undercutting
them on the black market and he died he
had a heart attack so here is what this
woman cash anna kelly writes in the new
york times she says other families could
devote themselves to spending time
together around tables piled with
celebrity food but the garner has had to
keep vigil around a hospital bed because
Erika suffered a heart attack on
Christmas Eve and spent most of the last
week in a coma she died on fairly young
at 27 that's three years after he died
her dad died on fairly young at 43 when
officer Daniel Pantaleo
of the Newark Police Department placed
him in a banned chokehold
so you'll number one have to ask why a
woman would have a heart attack at 27
right and that's not that's not fall to
the cops right well if you have a heart
attack at 27 and that's because you
either have a congenital heart situation
or because you have a severe weight
problem which could also be congenital
that leads to heart disease right
Erika Garner had two kids if both she
and her dad had been alive this holiday
season they would have almost certainly
spent it together he was a family man
she said about it's all very sad
obviously but here's where she starts to
go off the rails this columnist she says
since the country's founding black
families have never been able to thrive
slavery broke them apart by allowing
family members to be sold at auctions to
different owners obviously true millions
of black family members were killed
during slavery and the lynching era from
1877 to 1950 I don't know about millions
I'd have to actually look up the
statistics about I don't think that
certainly millions of people are not
lynched during that period that's that's
a that's a wild exaggeration in terms of
lynching itself in terms of black family
members who died I mean I assume the
desk millions black defendants often
received far longer sentences than
similarly situated white defendants so
the idea here is that black families are
being destroyed by the constant ongoing
oppression this was true during slavery
not as for during Jim Crow because even
under Jim Crow families could live
together I mean once you are free to
marry then it is your responsibility to
stay with your kids right the fact is
that the the black single motherhood
rate in 1960 was 20% today it's 70% how
is that the fault of American government
per se other than a welfare system that
incentivizes men not to stick around and
incentivizes women not to get married
before having babies it's it's difficult
for me to imagine how you can blame
slavery for a in elevation a three
hundred and fifty percent elevation in
the black single motherhood rate since
the advent of the civil rights movement
essentially that's it's a very weird
contention but the idea here is that
it's all the fault of the system that
black families are disproportionately
affected by child protection systems I
haven't seen the evidence for that
she says she concludes by suggesting if
there is no sin in killing Eric garner
no crime then black families like the
Garner's can be destroyed without anyone
having to answer for it now we can go
over the garner case again but the idea
that most black families are being
destroyed by the system is just not true
most black families are not in place in
the first place in the sense of a mother
and father who are married having kids
most black families are not made like
that it's not like they're married
couples there
broken up by the state as it was the
case during slavery that's not what's
happening here and to pretend otherwise
is just to be non factual speaking of
non-factual there are a lot of people
who are talking this week about the new
statistics out from New York City where
murders are down again and the crime
levels are really low and they're
suggesting that this is because of the
end of stop and frisk that stop and
frisk it turns out didn't do anything I
find the evidence on this strangely
weird you can't use New York City as the
only evidence of proactive policing
proactive policing has stopped in places
like Ferguson and Baltimore the crime
rate has risen dramatically proactive
policing has stopped in Los Angeles in
Detroit the crime rate has risen
dramatically in New York City one of the
reasons the crime rate has not written
dramatically the risen dramatically is
because stop and frisk was so it was so
thorough and because the policing was so
proactive for literally decades I mean
New York City coined this stuff then now
you're seeing the kind of trailing
effect Heather McDonald is a very good
piece you should go over and check it
out in City Journal all about what's
happened demographically in the city of
New York and what she basically says is
that the areas that were responsible for
super high crime in New York have
largely become Denver gentrified as a
result of good policing and so you're
now seeing the evolutionary overhang of
good crime policies and if you continue
to have bad crime policies eventually
then you will see a breakdown again but
you won't see it in most gentrified
areas you'll see in areas that are not
as gentrified ok a quick final thing
we'll deconstruct the culture very
briefly so Justin Timberlake has a new
video out as you know I love Justin
Timberlake I don't I don't know anything
about Justin Timberlake except that he
grabs Janet Jackson's boob occasionally
in any case John Justin Timberlake has
cut a new video the part that I find
noteworthy about this is that the left
is going crazy about this music video
and I really don't see why so here it is
it's produced by Pharrell and his wife
Jessica Biel is is they're in a
voiceover so here is the the trailer for
his album man of the woods
this album is really inspired by my son
my wife my family but more so than any
other album I've ever written where I'm
from and it's personal
[Music]
Justin Timberlake loves nature man it's
it's fire okay so in any case the reason
that this is noteworthy is because first
of all Justin Timberlake is from
Tennessee right he is from Tennessee so
people have freedom like you - oh look
look at this look at the city boy going
and acting like he likes all the nature
and such okay he is from Memphis
Tennessee
he grew up in Shelby Forest which is a
small community between Memphis and
Millington I know this because of dr.
Wikipedia right is this idea that he has
no connection with sort of the country
is just silly
but there are bunch of people who are
pissed about it so there's it there's an
article in a an outlet called the
outline where they say Justin Timberlake
is rebranding as a white man he's
embracing his authentic roots rebranding
is white what was he ever black tan I
missed that part because I'm pretty
aware that everybody knew that he was
white for like his entire life because
he's white but he's a rebranding as a
white man to go back to where you're
from I mean he's from Memphis I just I
don't understand this but again the
race-baiting is so thorough here that if
you are if you're a guy who wears a
cowboy hat you want to talk about kind
of cultural cultural discrimination if
you are a white guy who wears a cowboy
hat or boots in a place with a bush then
all of a sudden you are considered a
hick who hates black people I mean
that's basically what the outline is
trying to say here there's literally
what they say I have to read this cuz
it's insane
they say the trailer for Timberlake's
new album man of the woods present the
former NSYNC heartthrob looking pensive
in various natural settings hitting
every note of the white man finding
himself in the empty West trope that has
long been part of America's romantic
fictional past well what now
like huh this is white colonialist
fantasies aside there's something very
familiar about this pivot and Timberlake
style white colonialist fantasy
he's literally standing on a rock I
don't see his slaves I don't see him
fighting with Native Americans right
what Pocahontas is nowhere to be found
but the insane race consciousness here
is just beyond so that what they're
saying is that Timberlake has a long
history with hip-hop and R&B genre is
invented and dominated by black people
and to be clear without
african-americans there would be no rock
or country music as we know it either
but I digress right say he moved from
quote/unquote black culture but now he's
pandering to white America um or maybe
he just wants to do an album about where
he's from is that possible okay what if
I just like jazz I like jazz not because
it was invented by black people but
because classic jazz is great stuff and
what if I like country music because I'm
Jewish like I have no connection I have
no real connection to any of these
musics probably more to jazz and I need
a country music but this this is this
notion that everything has to be broken
down by sort of cultural stereotype it
just demonstrates the intersectional
stupidity of so many people who are
commentators in our culture I don't see
what Justin Timberlake is doing wrong by
standing in a jacket in a forest like
the forests belong to us all okay enough
enough okay so we will be back we will
be back here at tomorrow with much much
more because there's always news
breaking and I assume president Trump
will have access to his Twitter so we'll
have a lot to talk about
I'm Ben Shapiro this venture Pierrot
show
the Ben Shapiro show is produced by
Mathis Glover executive producer Jeremy
boring senior producer Jonathan hey our
technical producer is Austin Stevens
edited by Alex's and Garo audio is mixed
by Mike Carmina hair and makeup is by
Jael para the Ben Shapiro show is a
daily wire for word publishing
production copyright Ford publishing